I could die before that I'm not giving
myself enough time wow
I'd like to show you how I'm working
with all business that we recently
started I'm the low we have a range of
um sizes and colors no one gets left out
and when you go to the checkout page if
you enter the code early five as you'll
see here you'll get five pounds off your
order this is a message to odd ads and I
saw your recent video in your friend's
Channel who does cars and you know specs
them out yeah yeah it's called and there
you say something very profound because
you said that about three a couple of
years ago that in three years time
you're going to believe in the music
industry and you believe it to be Haram
alhamdulillah it's a good sign that the
fact that you acknowledge that what you
do in this Haram it's it's good sign
instead of just a finance this is what
you had to say which I found very
profound and it makes me believe that
shaytan is outright at war with all of
us including me but he's got you he's
tricked you to thinking something which
can be at your demise and I want the
best for you inshallah Aki here is what
he had to say and let's see what we can
dissect yeah you said three years and
you're out and you're done
talk to me is that true I want it to be
true all right if I go and study My
Religion at 30 35 and the life
expectancy is seven e68 as a man and I
could die before that I'm not giving
myself enough time
wow okay
down to 35 but I don't want it to okay
guys so we saw for ourselves the biggest
way shaytan gets guys this is his like
this is this is It's a job that he's
perfected to knock out to make us think
that we have enough time
yeah and this is from shaytan this
cannot be from him yeah this is from
shaytime okay that he's saying that he
wants to he he made intentions and
that's going to get reward for your
intention the [ __ ] you intended
something and you don't do you get a
reward and if you do you get 10 rewards
so this is the beauty of Islam so the
fact that you meet intentions to leave
the music industry and you still have it
in your struggling you're still you've
got that battle alhamdulillah carry on
fighting now the thing is this though
you said that your cap is 35 by 35
definitely want to leave it because you
want to give yourself enough time
because there's life expectancy 70. my
dear brother my dear brother yeah Allah
says every social taste deaf
iblies is an enemy brother if at least
is an enemy you need to understand Iblis
is never going to come and say to you
you know what well you can die tomorrow
he's going to tell you that we think
that death is so far away guys let me
ask you a question are we more closer to
living or closer to death the fact that
I can die any second means I am more
closer to death and I'm more close to
the Hereafter now if I look closer to
death and I'm more closer to the
Hereafter which one shall I prioritize
more death or life this doesn't mean you
don't live and work I'm not saying that
this life or the hairafter if I know I'm
closer to death and close to the
Hereafter I would have to I mean anyone
in the right mind would have to be like
well I have to work should work towards
that now when we go and get transit like
when we go travel and we stop transistor
yeah let's say in Dubai yeah do we ever
say to ourselves yo listen let me plan
here let me do some investment let me go
to buy a house let me go get married
here no because you know you're here for
maybe four hours three hours five hours
eight hours 12 hours a day max you don't
plan it just like let me get a look
listen I'm just gonna give my little
bits and Bobs here yeah I'm gonna get
through to cook because if I just get
takeaway because I'm going to be here
for not for that long yeah let me just
quickly book a simple Hotel nothing
luxury because I'm just going to be here
what's the point of spending that much
look at how we think why do we not
Implement that to to the hair after 35
is not promised do you know how many
people shaytan tricks and makes you
believe Bro you've got time you've got
time life expectancy what does that mean
this is where the shaytan makes us take
the uncle our logic over the knuckle
which is Allah's text Allah has given us
ample evidence Aki that we can look
death is around the corner the process
center that is the destroyer of
Pleasures yeah that we can go any second
so the fact that we're thinking of
logically like oh what's the life
expectancy 70. who said you're going to
lift the 70. who's
the 35 we think these ratios like oh
what's the chances of me getting in a
car accident one in four million okay
good this is taking our logic and that's
exactly what crochetan to fall into this
disbelief why because when Allah told
him to bow down to Adam he said
logically what logically it doesn't make
sense because I believe logically that I
am better than him why is Allah telling
me to do something that is illogical to
me that is what caused him to disbelieve
because he is now questioning Allah when
Allah tells you to do something you if
you acknowledge he's the unknowing you
do it even if it sounds ridiculous you
do it why because it's coming from Allah
my logic is limited and that's the
reason why I've done this please send
this to art at Aki this is a great
deception of shaytan to make you believe
you've got so many years this many years
many people thought this and guess what
they thought I'll change tomorrow I'm
doing this now I'm selling drugs I'm
doing that I'll sell it tomorrow I mean
I'll stop tomorrow and they
and they die
and shaytan wins
that's all I wanted to say may Allah
preserve you inshallah and keep you
guided inshallah please please bear this
in my Anarchy do those changes right now
I know it's hard but Salah
um fasting incorporate that now do not
wait you know hopefully may Allah bless
you I'm not saying that you don't we'll
probably do that but the music industry
bro work on it now Allah will provide
for you Aki don't ever think again with
your logic oh but if I do I'm gonna uh
earn Allah will provide he's created the
whole universe he will provide give the
shaytan The Knockout blow I say I'm
leaving this industry I'm leaving it no
matter what happens no matter what I
Lose I'm leaving it and watch how Allah
gives you more and like he says
if you fear me I will give you odd ads a
way out from places you never imagined
and while witness to that in my life may
Allah